qui a fait loin d'être la seule cible de
l'armée russe de violents combats se
poursuivent dans toute l'ukraine moscou
a annoncé hier élargir son offensive à
l'ensemble du pays l'armée russe en
cercle deux grandes villes du pays au
sud il y avait aussi eu une percée dans
la ville de kharkiv deuxième grande
ville du pays de plus d'un million
d'habitants les ukrainiens 10e
aujourd'hui garder le contrôle de cette
ville on retrouve gulliver crâne notre
correspondant en ukraine dans un village
ou un missile vient d'être abattu que
s'est il passé exactement
alors je suis à gauche qu'il fit un
petit village dans le centre de
l'ukraine où ce matin vers 9 heures du
matin le système anti-roquettes
ukrainien a abattu une roquette que j'ai
entendu d'ailleurs passé c'était juste
avant mon direct de ce matin mais la
requête est donc tombé sur ce village
dans le champ où je me trouve
actuellement et causant des dommages à
plusieurs bâtiments à côté je pense que
vous voyez derrière moi il ya une grange
dans le toit est complètement cassé et
la maison un peu plus loin était une
maison en construction
son propriétaire m'a dit que cela
faisait cinq ans qu'avec sa famille
construisait cette maison il s'apprêtait
à 6 aménagé et bien maintenant cet
aménagement au moins sera retardé il y a
je voulais dit ouais plusieurs maisons
autour si on les fenêtres cassées bien
sûr les habitants de ce village ne
s'attendait pas du tout à être ciblés
dans cette guerre ils sont vraiment loin
de tout cibles stratégiques si ce n'est
la petite base militaire à kalinka une
ville voisine et les habitants ici pense
que c'était sans doute la base militaire
la kalinka qui était la cible de cette
requête et donc ils ont dit heureusement
que les et craignant l'onta baticle et
système anti roquette a pu la battre
parce que au moins ici personne n'a été
blessé personne n'a été tué et là bas il
y aurait pu avoir de plusieurs soldats
qui auraient pu perdre la vie quel est
le degré de mobilisation des jeunes
hommes et des hommes plus généralement
pour s'engager pour défendre le pays
ici là où on est c'est vraiment très
très impressionnant comment presque tous
les hommes on a l'impression est pas que
les hommes les femmes aussi sont
mobilisés pour faire ce qu'il peut les
hommes s'engagent temps unité de défense
territoriale
ceux qui ne sont plus en âge militaire
ou qui ont des problèmes de santé qui
leur permettent pas de sortir font
d'autres choses on a vu des gens
construire des barricades sur les routes
ce matin est apparue une barricade
qu'ils n'étaient pas là hier soir par
exemple et on a aussi vu à l'un de ces
barricades ont fait là où on nous a
arrêtés pour contrôler nos documents la
voiture de devant était plein de
cocktails molotov les gens nous ont
raconté que les amener ces colloques
cocktails molotov à la mairie d'un
village voisin juste pour être préparé
au cas où ils nous ont pas dit s'ils ont
des indications que les russes font est
réussie bientôt mais ils ont dit qu'il
faut s'y préparer parce que visiblement
il y a une au possible qui se poursuit
sur sous le pays merci beaucoup
d'univers craag merci à